good evening tonight las vegas is
remembering a legend
siegfried fishbacher from the iconic
show zigfried and roy
died last night thanks for joining us
here at five i'm denise valdez
good evening i'm brian loft is this
after his battle with
pancreatic cancer we are now joined by
christian cazares live just outside of
the mirage on the strip with a bit more
on his legacy and how loyal fans are
remembering him
that's right denise brian good afternoon
well i can tell you that fans of both
siegfried and roy have been coming out
here throughout the day
basically paying their respects now roy
horn passed away
last year and today siegfried basically
ended
that long legacy right here in las vegas
now take a look
at where we're at now we're basically
outside
the mirage here on las vegas boulevard
where you can see the statue of the
performers
along with the famous tiger from their
show and a few candles also here left
behind
by some of their fans now siegfried
passed away last night
at his home in las vegas after a long
battle with pancreatic cancer
the famous duo started their bond back
in the 1950s
when they met on a cruise ship and
started an act that basically catapulted
them to las vegas where they performed
at the new frontier mgm grand known as
the valleys
the stardust and eventually the mirage
they were known for their magic and
illusions but also
for incorporating live animals like
tigers and elephants
into their act it brought so much to las
vegas
with the shows and opened a lot of doors
for i mean look if you look around now
look at all these acts that we
have
well in may of last year as i mentioned
roy passed away at the age of 75
after contracting covet 19 and instantly
the love from his fans was felt
now the same fans are mourning the end
of a las vegas legacy now back out here
live i can tell you that mgm resorts
just announced that they will be paying
tribute to siegfried on all of their las
vegas properties
on their marquee starting at five
o'clock also the fremont street
experience will also be paying a tribute
to siegfried tonight from eight o'clock
all the way
through midnight christian casarez 8
news now
christian thank you well tributes to
zigfried fishbacher just
pouring in this morning following the
news mgm resorts saying quote
the passing of siegfried marks an end of
an era
zigfried and roy had a vision for the
kind of entertainment spectacular
the world at large really had never seen
before and also tonight here at five
david copperfield said quote
his legacy will live on not only in
magic but in truly
shaping the history and the future of
this city
we have more statements for you on
8newsnow.com
on facebook viewer faye abel says we've
lost two legends that can never
be replaced las vegas should be honored
to have had them
and britney swindle beal says now you
can perform magic again
we'll always cherish the years that i
worked in your showroom